uh mark go ahead in pennsylvania my wife
and i we have a threesome scheduled uh
it's our first one so i wanted to uh see
if you or anybody else had any uh advice
for jumping into it uh we've been yeah
where do you schedule that where do you
go
you've come to the we've already met her
you know we
didn't meet a meet and greet and had
some drinks and had a great vibe and uh
who really just clicked so we're super
excited you know sending messages back
and forth sending pictures talking about
she's done it a couple times uh my wife
and i have not should we go to our
resident sex expert ronnie is uh
ronnie oh yeah i'm sure he claims to
know everything he can does he know all
the rules this guy's just got too much
planning going on like the couple of
times that i you know had this situation
it's like you meet the girl you're
hanging out
uh you have like you said you have you
probably having a few drinks or whatever
but then that's it
like the one time i did we met this girl
and
with you know everybody hit it off
and she when we took her to her
apartment she packed up her clothes and
we came to my house for the weekend
wow
there was no days in between she packed
up all her clothes and then came over to
your place and hung the whole weekend
stayed the whole [ __ ] weekend and
we're sitting there all drinking and
everything it's three in the morning and
we're playing [ __ ] monopoly is that
dangerous ronnie we did have rules the
rules were
that
i didn't even [ __ ] this girl
to be honest with you everything right
everything but [ __ ] her
right the only one i [ __ ] was the girl
you know my girl that's it right well
wait a minute when you say everything
but
well you mean making out
yeah that you could
okay you're saying it was sort of
exciting to see the two girls getting it
on and then like you could yeah i mean
you you know you haven't drink you know
you're drinking during
that's it that's the bottom line yeah
well like ronnie had so many things he
couldn't do that he just ended up doing
the laundry during it and then he came
back in when it was over ronnie you you
should become like a threesome counselor
i think you're making a lot of sense i
think you got something to say